قصتنا اليوم من الشارع الروسي وتحديدا في
العاصمه موسكو حيث درجه التجمد الان تقترب
من الثلاثين تحت الصفر بطلنا اشتهر باسم
افران روسو هو فنان وملحن وبلاد الطرب
والقدود الحلبيه عاش قرابه 25 عاما بين
سوريا ولبنان واحيا حفلات متنوعه في كثير
من الدول العربيه هاجر بعضها الى قبرص ومن
هناك قرر الرحيل الى روسيا مشواره الفني
هناك اوصله للنجوميه واصبح يقدم حفلات
بعدد ايام السنه تقريبا خلال العام الواحد
في ارجاء العالم اغاني يتخطت شهرتها قرابه
نصف مليار مشاهده واستماع وكان في قائمه
الطب للمغنيين في اوروبا الشرقيه لعشر
سنوات
اليوم متابعه من ملايين على انستغرام
وغيرها من مواقع التواصل
سباق سباق
[موسيقى]
في العالم بدات في دمشق انتقلت الى لبنان
الاردن الكويت مصر العراق
ارمينيا قبرص روسيا والان في امريكا تعيش
الان بين امريكا
الاكثر سخونه في 2023 شو الرحله المكوكيه
هاي شو هال- الجراه على الاقدام على
الخطوات
ما بتنقي انت الحياه فالحياه بيجبرك عارف
شلون تعيش
بالشرق الاوسط فوق 25 سنه
اكيد اكيد 16 سنه بلاش تغني اول اول بدايه
المشوار يعني كان صعب كثير لحد الان صعب
ما في شيء هايم بهالدنيا عروس شلون فحولت
من بلد لثانيه يعني بيسموه الجيبسيس يعني
كانوا كانوا نور كيف عايش نفس القصه بس
انه
دخلت صار عندي اسم بيروسيا
رهيب
لو سمحت انا بعرف انه في عندك حفلات امام
العديد من الرؤساء لكن من الاسماء اللامعه
اللي اشتغلت معها ان كانت بروسيا او
اشتغلت معها بالعالم العربي حتى نعرف
القيم وكلمات والحال مين شغلات كريستيانو
مثلا
وام كلثوم
ندى ههه
حابين نسمع منك شيء كخليط بين الروسي
والعربي من اللي بتقدموا على المسارح بدنا
الكلام
المقطع العربي الي زمان سجلته بمصر بس
مغنينا الاغنيه بس ضربته هون ضربه قويه
يعني ناس
سبتها ما اعرفش انا ليه سبتها
معرفش ان انا غلطان
وهعيش بعدها ندمان اه
سبتك
جبتها
سبت لها دموع وجراح ويا ريتني يعيش بعد
مرتاح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]